oui j'ai besoin de quatre pour le père
noël
c'est un bon feu s'ils passent par là a
bien du kram et le coup
ce gros bâtards joyeux vous avez
commencé sans nous ou bien le loup
l'étude va with you toi qu'est ce que tu
fais est excellent mais qu'est ce que tu
viens faire ici tu devais passer la
soirée chez elton john ami ben haddou
n'est pas du tout je ne vois pas du tout
pourquoi pas du tout très bien on se
rassemble autour de leur donnerait les
moyens de faire des cadeaux pour sceller
notre amitié je te donner quelque chose
j'étais
qu'est ce que c'est c'est quoi j'ai pas
une chaînette c'est pas une gourmette
écouter de l'extérieur c'est magnifique
oh oh oh ce qui s'appelle être gâtés
pourris à noël le garder accroupis des
narguilés et cafetière qui était content
il est rom de terre frites sont forts
ces arabes incassable c'est à dire non
s'est clos le cadeau pour la reine des
faits il est celle qui a donc j'ai fait
pareil
bon cv dessus quand je suis content j'ai
mûri et je suis hyper content et c'est
pour qui suit merveilles du chocolat
latence
tiens